police in India controlled Kashmir have
detained more than 140 children since
the start of August now according to a
report requested by India that Supreme
Court amid increasing concern about
detention of kids
Kashmir's police chief says young people
found to be breaking the law are
strictly dealt with but denies they're
being held illegally the Indian
government's being been deploying
additional troops to Kashmir since
revoking its special status almost two
months ago it's also suspended telephone
and Internet communications and imposed
a curfew on people living there citing
security concerns
our correspondent Paula slayers talked
to people living in the Pakistan
controlled part of the disputed
territory I'm here in Pakistan
controlled Kashmir where many people are
simply fed up they believe the
international community is not doing
enough to help their friends and family
across the ceasefire line and so this
group of men are planning a humanitarian
response to take medicines and food
across the ceasefire line
are you expecting that the Indian
soldiers are going to fire on you Amata
bhaiya
if our brothers are getting killed and
our sisters are being raped how can we
sit and do nothing we will go there and
try to save them from this Indian
brutality even if it costs us our lives
we will do what we can
if the survial United Nations won't do
anything they should come forward and
play a vital role in resolving this
matter they exist for that very purpose
in common we are a second fighting for
the last seven to two years our right of
self-determination that has been
deprived by the India India has decided
to change the demography of the valley
as they have changed in last 30 years
the province of Jammu so we shall not
allow India to do this to continue this
genocide they've been planning this for
one and a half months and now they're
gonna show me how exactly it's gonna
work
there are about fifty thousand to one
lakh people throughout the Sgt Kashmir
are gathered to across the LOC from the
different processing point all the
people regardless of their organization
regardless leaders of their religious
are frustrated to help the people living
in the Union occupied which means so
this is one of the private hospitals
here what would you be doing here so
this is a private hospital we collect
medical supply from many private
hospitals and Muzaffarabad and boluses
and medical kits so in union-occupied
which meet people need this Indian
forces not allowed to go to the hospital
so this is their basic human rights we
have a lot of stock image of Chabad in
many hospitals so we collect on them and
put them in ambulances so and we make a
convoy towards the city Nagar in cross
the Yellow Sea this is our plan so what
kind of foods will you be taking with
you we take all these Goods one needs in
our daily the kitchen needs like beans
like rice like cooking wild life floor
we take this one we take this one we
take this one we take this ones and also
some children force all these foods are
shortened in an in Occupied Kashmir and
we go far has a hominin Terry in it we
not cross the LOC to fight for to
someone we are only going to support and
to aid the people's were suffer in this
curfew in Indian Occupied Kashmir and we
hope that all securities of Pakistan in
Indian side also allow us to go to in in
Occupied Kashmir well it remains to be
seen what transpires but the countdown
has begun
policia Aarti Kashmir
Vijay chart I well from the ruling BJP
party in India gave us his views a long
peg there is a unanimous resolution in
Indian Parliament which was supported by
all the parties saying that the
currently occupy Kashmir is also a part
of India and it has we have been
illegally annexed by Pakistan Jammu and
Kashmir is an integral part of India
there is no question or demo referendum
because even in that time the referendum
was supposed to be on the other side of
Kashmir also which Pakistan ready for
the referendum on their part of Kashmir
which is which they are requiring no the
referendum cannot be easy like that we
are always in favor of resolving all the
issues bilateral issues in a peaceful
manner but terrorism which is instigated
from Pakistani side is always a matter
of concern for us it is a security issue
for us and we will take a strong step
against it whatever required